A no ser que vivas en una cueva y tu
único medio de información sea VISUALPOLITIK
... en cuyo caso ¡Gracias! Sigue así :)
Te habrás enterado de que FIDEL CASTRO
ha muerto y con él muere todo un
icono del comunismo que gobernó Cuba
con mano de hierro durante más de 50 años.
Muchos se preguntan hoy si la muerte de
Fidel Castro marcará un periodo de
transición en Cuba entre lo que es una
dictadura comunista hacia una democracia
de libre mercado. Pero lo cierto es que
ya en el año 2008, Fidel pasó el poder
a su hermano pequeño, Raúl Castro.
Como veis, todo queda en casa. Y lo cierto es
que a Raúl no le ha quedado más
remedio que aplicar una serie de
reformas que hace años serían
impensables en un régimen que presumía
de mantener puras las esencias del
comunismo tradicional.  Está claro que el
castrismo,
al menos tal y como lo conocemos, es un
sistema agotado. Y no sabemos en qué se
va a convertir Cuba pero sí sabemos que
está cambiando y todo esto dará mucho
que hablar a los medios de comunicación
durante los próximos meses. Pero nos
habéis pedido que hagamos un video
especial hablando sobre Cuba y, cómo
sabéis, en VisualPolitik nos gusta
siempre darle una vuelta de tuerca a la
noticia. Porque hay una pregunta muy
importante que queda en el aire: ¿Ha
llegado ya el momento de invertir en
Cuba? ¿Se puede ganar dinero gracias a los
cambios que se esperan en este país?
Hoy vamos a responder esta pregunta.
La historia nos demuestra que cuando un
país pasa de una economía planificada
a una de libre mercado, se abre una
ventana de oportunidad en la que es
posible hacer mucho dinero.
Buena muestra de ello es esta casa desde la
que os habló. Que los que seguís VisualPolitik
desde hace tiempo
sabéis que está en Praga, República Checa.
El edificio entero en el que vivo
es propiedad de un italiano que lo
compró a principios de los años 90.
Y es que, en aquella época, República Checa
estaba empezando a abrir su
economía tras varias décadas de
comunismo.
Eso significa que, por primera vez, se
podían comprar y vender viviendas.
¡Pero no sólo eso! Como el país era
relativamente pobre,
el precio de las casas era muy bajo y
eso atrajo a un montón de inversores
extranjeros (sobre todo del Norte de
Italia) que compraron bloques enteros de
apartamentos a precio de saldo.
Años más tarde, la economía checa
empezó a crecer muy rápidamente.
Llegaron a empresas extranjeras turismo,
etcétera...
Así que en poco tiempo esos pisos
duplicaron su valor convirtiendo sus
propietarios en millonarios.
Algo muy parecido podría ocurrir en Cuba.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no
es oro todo lo que reluce! Otros países
ex comunistas como Ucrania no han
corrido la misma suerte y han arruinado
a más de un inversor. Y por eso es tan
importante entender la situación de
Cuba y el rumbo de las reformas que
están tomando. Pero antes vamos a ver un
poco de perspectiva histórica.
"La situación de Cuba hoy en día"
Como os decía Cuba es un país comunista.
Eso significa que toda la economía
está controlada por el estado.
Eso significa que, en su mejor momento, el
estado empleaba al 92% de la población
activa. Es decir que prácticamente todo
el mundo trabajaba para el sector público.
Esto eran los años 80, cuando
Cuba exportaba azúcar, tabaco, y todo
tipo de frutas a la URSS.
Sin embargo, en 1989, cayó el Muro de
Berlín y Cuba perdió a su principal
socio comercial.
Si a eso le sumamos el embargo comercial
de EEUU, que prohíbe a sus
empresas a hacer cualquier tipo de
negocios con la isla,
tenemos que Cuba estaba prácticamente
aislado en el mundo y eso se tradujo en
una crisis BESTIAL
que se prolongó hasta el año 2000,
año en el que Hugo Chávez se hace
con el poder en Venezuela.
Como ya os contamos en este otro vídeo,
Venezuela era un país muy rico gracias
a sus inmensas reservas de petróleo. Y
cómo Castro y Chávez eran muy amigos,
Cuba empezó a recibir millones de
petrodólares de Venezuela.
Esto supuso todo un balón de oxígeno
para el régimen castrista.
Sin embargo, en el año 2013, el precio
del petróleo cae en picado y Venezuela se derrumbó.
Y con ella también se hundió Cuba.
En este momento, Fidel Castro ya se
había jubilado y Raúl Castro era quien
llevaba las riendas del gobierno. Raúl
se da cuenta de que está aislado en
este mundo y que si no cambia las cosas...
lo va a pasar muy mal.
"LAS REFORMAS CHINAS DE RAÚL CASTRO"
Por cierto, que esto tan afrodisiaco que
está sonando es la música de Rik, un
cantante, compositor, y guitarrista de
Medellín, en Colombia, que nos ha enviado
su música.
Si os gusta encontraréis el link a su
canal de youtube en los enlaces de la
describieron.
En ese mismo año 2013,
Raúl Castro anunció una serie de
reformas muy significativas.
La primera es la legalización de los
llamados CUENTAPROPISTAS, que son algo
parecido a los profesionales autónomos.
Es decir, que por primera vez a los
cubanos se les permite tener pequeños
negocios.
Por supuesto que con muchísimas
restricciones. De entrada no pueden
contratar a nadie y sólo pueden
trabajar en una serie de sectores
permitidos por el estado. Sin embargo, en
sólo tres años, los cuentapropistas
suponen ya el 10% de la población
activa cubana.
"Existe el miedo ese de que si tu hacías algo
particular antes, te lo quitaban...
osea... ya no, eso ya no osea... se abolió ya eso, osea...
ahora el Gobierno del Estado Cubano
tiene una plena confianza en los
cuentapropistas porque es el futuro"
¡Pero esperad de un momento porque hay mucho más!
Lo cierto es que Raúl Castro parece
estar imitando el modelo del Partido
Comunista Chino, del que, por cierto,
hablaremos la próxima semana.
De hecho al más puro estilo DEN XIAOPING
Raúl Castro ha creado también
una Zona Económica Especial a la que ha
llamado el Centro de Desarrollo Mariel
¿Y esto qué significa? Pues que
dentro de esta zona pueden instalarse
empresas extranjeras, contratar cubanos,
tener beneficios y todo esto con muchas
menos restricciones que en el
resto de Cuba.
"Cinco empresas extranjeras, dos cubanas y
una mixta son las primeras ocho
entidades presentes actualmente en la
zona especial de desarrollo de MARIEL,
la cual se convertirá en el principal
polo económico de Cuba"
Y preguntaréis ¿Cómo es posible que
hoteles Barceló que es una empresa
española, pueda estar trabajando en Cuba,
cuando, supuestamente, está prohibida la
entrada de empresas extranjeras? Porque
seguramente muchos de los que estáis
viendo este vídeo os hayáis sido en
algún momento de vacaciones a la Habana
y es hayáis hospedado en un hotel de la
cadena Meliá, y hoteles Barceló son
cadenas de hoteles españolas. Y que
llevan operando en este país desde el
año 2000. Pero lo cierto
es que para poder trabajar en Cuba, tanto
hoteles Barceló como hoteles Meliá tuvieron que
hacer un acuerdo de asociación con el
Gobierno Cubano. Es decir, que los hoteles
son propiedad del estado y las empresas
simplemente se dedican a gestionar, a
explotarlos y a llevarse parte de los
beneficios.
Nada más. Es decir que hasta ahora era
imposible montar cualquier negocio en
Cuba.
A no ser que te asociaras con el
gobierno cubano. Sin embargo la creación
de esta zona económica especial marca
una tendencia muy clara y es lo mismo
que hizo China en los años 80.
A esto hay que sumarle la legalización
de la compraventa de viviendas. En sólo
dos años se han vendido más de 40.000
casas en Cuba.
¡OJO! Esto no significa que tengan
propiedad privada y por supuesto que
todas estas operaciones comerciales han
tenido un montón de restricciones pero
no olvidemos que aquí estamos hablando
de una tendencia.
Pero lo más importante de todo fue el
anuncio de Obama de poner fin al embargo
comercial.
¿El problema? Que todavía no se ha
aprobado en el Congreso de EEUU
y que con DONALD TRUMP de
presidente, es muy difícil predecir lo
que va a pasar.
"Una compañía controlada
por Donald Trump llevó a
cabo negocios de forma secreta en Cuba.
Durante la presidencia de Fidel Castro a
pesar de las estrictas prohibiciones, hay
estadounidenses que hacen estas
prácticas ilegales".
En cualquier caso, si Trump mantuviera el
bloqueo comercial a Cuba no tendría por
qué ser una mala noticia.
Al menos no para los inversores
latinoamericanos y españoles. Porque si
los estadounidenses no pueden hacer
negocios con Cuba, están dejando vía
libre para que entren todos los demás.
¡Pero esperado momento porque nada de
esto significa que Cuba vaya a
convertirse en un paraíso de libertad
desde la noche a la mañana! ¡Ni siquiera
que sea una buena oportunidad para
invertir dinero!  En realidad pueden darse
dos escenarios: o bien Cuba apuesta por
una transición al estilo de
Checoslovaquia (lo que ahora es
República Checa) o bien elige un modelo
más parecido al de Ucrania.
Vamos a ver ahora estos dos modelos.
"CHECOSLOVAQUIA FRENTE A UCRANIA"
En 1990, tanto Ucrania como Checoslovaquia abandonaron el comunismo.
Pero con una diferencia muy importante.
Los checoslovacos habían hecho toda una
revolución, la revolución de terciopelo,
para derrocar a su dictador. Y el nuevo
gobierno democrático, dirigido por este
señor que veis aquí, que se llamaba
VACLAV HAVEL, mandó a casa a todos los
antiguos gerifaltes de la dictadura.
En Ucrania, sin embargo, mantuvieron a toda
su clase política y eso que, en este
caso, el país si acababa de independizar
de la Unión Soviética (URSS).
Lo cierto es que es un nuevo presidente
LEONID KRAVCHUK, venía del mismísimo
Partido Comunista Soviético.
Así que era un cambio de régimen pero
con las mismas personas. Pero esto no es
todo porque tanto Cuba, como Ucrania, como
Checoslovaquia eran economías
planificadas donde todas las empresas
pertenecían al estado. Así que el
primer paso para abrir la economía
consistía en privatizarlas. ¡Pero ojo!
Porque nada todas las privatizaciones
son iguales.
Los checos cogieron a todas sus
empresas hicieron un cálculo económico
de su valor y los dividieron en
pequeñas participaciones o "vales".
Si tú eras un ciudadano checo, tenías
el derecho a comprar uno de estos vales
a un precio muy razonable.
Básicamente el equivalente a una semana
de sueldo. De hecho, el 80% de los
ciudadanos lo compró. Y con ese papel en
la mano tenías derecho a poder
participar en una subasta para comprar
acciones de las empresas checas. Incluso
si no sabías muy bien cómo hacerlo, el
propio gobierno checo impulsó la
creación de fondos de inversión.
Estos fondos te podría asesorar para
que pudieras invertir tu dinero de forma
inteligente... y te decían
pues te merece la pena comprar x
acciones de esta empresa o de esta otra...
Por supuesto que todo esto generó
muchísima corrupción pero también
consiguió que la mayoría de los
ciudadanos se beneficiarán de las
privatizaciones y además se terminaron
de hacer en muy poquitos años. Y la
prueba es que a día de hoy República Checa
es un país tan igualitario como
pueda serlo Alemania y con un nivel de
vida comparable al de cualquier país
europeo.
El caso de Ucrania es distinto es verdad
que también decidieron vender
participaciones o vales a sus ciudadanos.
Es decir que si tú eras un ucraniano
también podías comprar tu papelito que
te daba derecho a ir a una subasta para
comprar acciones de empresas ucranianas.
Pero el problema es que el gobierno
subastó muy poquitas empresas y las que
vendió fueron las menos importantes.
Así que la mayor parte de los
ciudadanos ucranianos estuvo durante
años en su casa con el papelito
esperando a poder cambiarlo por algo de valor.
Mientras tanto, Ucrania tenía una
inflación bestial.
Así que estos vales que al principio
cuando se emitieron valían más o menos
unos 1500 dólares (USD),
de repente se vendían en el mercado
negro por menos de 10. Así que, en
cualquier momento, podía llegar el
oligarca de turno y decirte: "mira chico
toma este dinero,
dame tu participación, que no te va a
servir de nada" Y justo en ese momento en
el que las participaciones de las
empresas estaban en manos de los amigos
del gobierno....
¡SORPRESA! En ese momento sí que se
subastaban las empresas importantes.
¿El resultado? Sólo se privatizaron
aquellas empresas que interesaban a los
gerifaltes del gobierno.
De hecho todavía quedan muchísimas
empresas públicas en Ucrania por
privatizar. Pero lo más importante es
que el 85% de la riqueza en
Ucranía está en manos de los 50
oligarcas más ricos.
Eso significa poca estabilidad política,
un clima horrendo para la
inversión y todo esto por no hablar de
la guerra con Rusia.
Así que si alguien compró viviendas en
KIEV hace 10 años, ahora seguramente
se estará dando cabezazos contra las paredes.
Pero volvamos a Cuba porque
aquí tenemos elementos parecidos a
Ucrania y elementos parecidos a
Checoslovaquia. Por un lado, Cuba está
controlada
prácticamente en su totalidad por una
familia, los Castro, que no van a dejar el
poder fácilmente.
Tampoco parece que exista ninguna figura
carismática como un Vaclav Havel
en Checoslovaquia. Alguien que tenga el
suficiente apoyo social como para poder
sustituir a la élite política
dominante. Pero por el otro lado,
Cuba tiene una diáspora muy grande y
muy influyente. Sólo en EEUU
hay más de dos millones de cubanos que
suponen el 20% de la población de Cuba.
Y estos cubanos han recibido una
educación democrática, tienen mucha
influencia política y podrían ayudar a
construir unas instituciones fuertes y
democráticas en La Habana.
Si esto fuera así, Cuba podría
convertirse en ese estado de derecho, con
buenas oportunidades para la inversión
y que además ayudaría a los cubanos a
salir de la pobreza.
La pregunta es ¿Qué crees que va a pasar?
¿Terminará Cuba pareciéndose más a
Ucrania o a República Checa?
Podéis dejarme la respuesta en los
comentarios y no olviden que sacamos
vídeos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones. Como siempre,
si alguien quiere profundizar más en
este tema, encontrará varios links en la
descripción. Si os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo.
¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!